yesterday mikhail gorbachev the final
secretary general of the soviet union
the man who with ronald reagan brought
about the peaceful end of the cold war
died at the age of 91.
some of our younger listeners might not
remember gorbachev
might not even know who he was gorbachev
was
at the time of his death quite elderly a
prominent figure in politics since the
1970s pretty much never had a job
outside of government
presided over the demise of a once
powerful nation and empire
his policies hastened his empire's
demise and he was a fellow traveler with
actual communists gorbachev was
in many ways a lot like joe biden but
that is not really fair to gorbachev and
i don't mean to speak ill of the dead
either gorbachev or biden gorbachev was
in many ways a much better man than joe
biden damning praise i know but he was
in many ways a great man in his own
right
reagan needed him to end the cold war
which occurred without a shot fired
and he was committed to a new course of
reform for his empire a new course
summed up in two policies glasnost and
perestroika
transparency in government and a
fundamental restructuring of the
political and economic order that is
probably the biggest difference of all
between biden and gorbachev the old top
commie was far more willing to root out
government corruption and give his
people an increased say in politics and
the economy then the big guy at 1600
pennsylvania right now ever would i'm
michael knowles this is the michael
knowles
[Music]
show welcome back to the show my
favorite comment yesterday is from a
heinz who says when i was younger much
younger i was a democrat and protested
and rebelled against the government and
now i'm old and a republican
once again i am rebelling against the
government isn't that amazing
everything old is new again
we have got to protect ourselves against
all sorts of problems including the
government that's why you gotta check
out ring right now head on over to
slash
ring.com
summer is busy it's busy for everyone
people go on vacation if you're me you
spend three days in the hospital because
your wife is giving birth to your second
beloved son either way you're going to
be away from home so you want to be able
to keep an eye on your home whether
you're there in the home whether you're
at the office whether you're on a beach
on the other side of the world ring can
do that you all know about the ring
video doorbell where you can see and
speak to whoever is at your door
wherever you are in the world did you
know that ring has an award-winning
alarm with available professional
monitoring when you subscribe well if
you didn't know that you certainly
should because then you can protect your
home you can keep an eye on your on your
windows on your doors on everything in
between but that's not all did you know
that ring has ring alarm pro that's what
cnet calls a giant leap for home
security where you protect not just your
physical home but your digital home too
well let's do it baby protect your
digital home with a very fast eero wi-fi
6 router
become a pro be a pro just like me this
summer go pro get ring alarm pro learn
more at ring.com knowles that is
ring.com
knowles
gorbachev died
at gorbachev i think is is the man that
we need right now i would i would
strongly support a gorbachev in 2024 the
policies we need right now give me the
republican who will run on glasnost and
perestroika because it is really
disturbing but 30 years after the fall
of the berlin wall the united states in
many ways resembles our old vanquished
foe the soviet union you've got this
weak economy you've got
political corruption everywhere you've
got the police the federal police force
being used essentially as a
the private security and bullying team
of the ruling party there's essentially
one ruling party in the country you've
imperial possessions falling apart
around the world we're not in a great
situation right now we're not in a great
situation
at all the difference is that gorbachev
was kind of lovable and joe biden is not
really lovable if biden never was
lovable which i don't
i never found him particularly
charming but a lot of people did that's
gone i mean a good old back slap and joe
i love you kid come on now jack hey come
on that guy's gone now he's just an
angry screaming old man who calls
everyone a racist and says half the
country is fascist unlike gorbachev who
will probably best be remembered in
terms of his actual appearances
video footage of him will probably best
be remembered after the fall of the
soviet union for starring in a pizza hut
commercial
[Music]
it's an amazing
[Music]
commercial walking around
moscow and then
we're going to sit standing up pizza
i'll translate it's gorbachev
it is
because of him
we have economic confusion
because of him we have opportunity
because of him
we have political instability because of
him we have freedom
complete chaos
instability
and then they all agree even the big
critic hail to gorbachev
[Music]
sometimes hell to gorbachev
[Applause]
this pizza hut commercial more than any
other symbol sums up the fall of the
soviet union
more than the fall of the berlin wall
the fact that you have the former soviet
leader
starring in a commercial for this
western capitalist chain pizza franchise
sums it all up
and what what it did sum up for the
russian people even in all of the
corruption and all the craziness that
surrounded the fall of the berlin wall
was economic opportunity okay we're
going to liberalize the markets we're
going to get the economy going again
after decades of decline
and
so gorbachev has this complicated legacy
but it does remind us of something
that's really important you need
economic
growth you need prosperity prosperity
will paper over a lot
of
bad things and because we don't have
that prosperity now because the economy
is
in the united states is in such a bad
shape because we've got 40-year high
inflation because of all the problems in
our economy all of those long-simmering
cultural tensions are are
bursting out into the open right now and
you've got the leader of our country
unlike the lovable peaceable gorbachev
you got the leader of our country joe
biden coming out calling half the
country fascist and then just yesterday
coming out and saying that we need to
give up our guns give up our second
amendment rights there's no way you'll
ever fight the government you're gonna
need an f-15 to fight the government
because we are gonna if we wanted to we
could put that boot on your neck so hard
you wouldn't know which end was up
the rights granted by the second
amendment are not unlimited
they're not unlimited
right now you can't go out and buy an
automatic weapon
you can't go out and buy a cannon
and for those brave right-wing americans
who say
it's all about shaping america you're
keeping america's independent and safe
if you want to fight against the country
you need a f-15 you need something a
little more than a gun
no i'm not joking think about this think
about the rationale we use
that's used to provide this and who they
shooting at
shooting at these guys behind me
so first of all on his
claims of fact they're just not true
you can you couldn't get a cannon yes
you could you can still by the way you
can still buy a cannon you ca if you
want to fight the government if you
wanted to fight the american government
you would need an f-15
you couldn't just have a gun um
that's interesting uh what what does
afghanistan have to say about that
because last time i checked
the
goat herders in afghanistan were able to
fend off the americans in a 20-year war
with little more than black powder
rifles
afghanistan is the size of texas
so no i think you could in this kind of
doomsday scenario where the government
turns to radical and starts attacking
the american people first of all you
don't think that some members of the u.s
military are going to defect at that
point i don't think
most military service members i know are
pretty patriotic people i don't think
they'd fire on their own citizens
furthermore you don't think that if a
bunch of afghani goat herders
could could defeat the united states in
a 20-year war
that the american people ourselves could
maybe push back a little against
corruption and abuse i think probably we
could
not i'm not not convinced of that
otherwise but furthermore joe biden
saying this sort of thing amounts to a
kind of a threat
right he's this is on the heels of biden
calling half the country fascist
biden calling half the country racist
and and saying that donald trump's a
a white nationalist and a racist and all
these things this is on the heels of the
biden's doj classifying parents who
don't want their kids to have their
genitals lopped off in school as
terrorists this is on the heels of biden
seeking the fbi on his predecessor in
chief political rival this is on the
heels of terrible economic growth this
is on the heels of weakness abroad
it's like it's 1989 all over again and
we're and but somehow the roles are
reversed and we're living in the soviet
union and unfortunately we don't have a
good leader like gorbachev running the
show it's like we've got i don't know
joe biden makes brezhnev look like a
youthful and vigorous person okay it's
like we've got all those old decrepit
you know weekend at bernie's kind of
soviet leaders that's who biden's like i
don't want to besmirch gorbachev's
memory by comparing him to him even the
the libs are
realizing this is just going too far
there's a cnn panel that just came out
and said hey biden
cool it with the fascist stuff
the term semi-fascist is not helpful
it's not befitting the office of
president and while you can absolutely
call out the dangers to our democracy
but it makes obviously perfect sense for
someone like senator hays and hassan
because look in new hampshire 40 more
than 40 percent of registered voters are
independents
right i mean another another another 30
and change of republicans democrats are
the third category among registered
registered voters so she needs to be
able to reach out and that language
doesn't help her do that and actually
you're being kind in terms of trying to
parse and put what he said into a
certain context the takeaway from
republicans is that the president of the
united states who campaigned on one on
and was sworn in on a message of unity
lowering the temperature and bringing
this country together just called half
of the country fascists
and you can parse it how you want but
that's the takeaway and then maggie
hassan was right he painted the
republican party as a bunch of fashion
this isn't a one-time thing i mean biden
has all the precision you know of a
surgeon with a meat axe here i mean when
when republicans wouldn't go along with
his bill to federalize all elections he
said well you're either jefferson davis
or bull connor i mean his natural
instinct is to go to an extreme insult
sort of so you're either racist or
you're a fascist
it's almost the whole panel there it's
not even just like the one lone sort of
fake conservative it's almost the whole
panel on cnn saying
biden is too far he's divisive he's
angry he's
he's
speaking in such a way that doesn't
befit the office of the president this
is cnn why why is cnn saying this is it
because they all of a sudden they got a
conscience i doubt it is it because all
of a sudden they're conservative i doubt
that too i think they're they're
saying we need to correct course here
because they realize that the people are
turning on them they're looking at the
generic congressional ballot they're
looking at the reaction of the actual
american people and they're saying yikes
we are losing them folks we need a
little glass in austin paris striker
here i think because that the current
leadership of this country the
democratic leadership is really really
bad and increasingly unpopular the libs
are going way way too far
the california state assembly has just
passed a bill
that seeks to establish california as a
sanctuary
for children seeking transgender medical
treatment as well as their pervert
parents who want to put the kids through
these kinds of genital mutilations and
experimental hormone
therapies the legislation is called
sb107
uh
the bill's author is senator scott
weiner
because all nature is but art unknown to
thee
because that's just a that's just
providence kind of winking i think just
the kind of
humorous order even to this very fallen
world uh winking through scott weiner if
you've heard that name before we've
mentioned him on the show scott weiner
is that sexual degenerate who made it
his mission his crusade in the
california legislature to soften the
punishments for pederasts for grown men
who have sex with little boys he said it
was very unfair there were there were
unfair and unequal treatments for pet
arrests and so scott weiner decided to
take up their cause and now in the least
surprising turn of events in the news
that you've ever seen the man the
degenerate who wanted to soften the
punishments for pederasty now wants a
bunch of sexually confused kids to come
to his state isn't that shocking never
never saw that one coming did you
sick stuff
only you know furthering the nickname
for los angeles and san francisco is
gamora sodom and gomorrah by the sea
uh really awful awful stuff everyone
involved in this this the senator scott
weiner the the parents the the doctors
these shaman witch doctor quacks who are
lopping off the genitals of kids or
pumping them full of hormones and and
puberty blockers to to get them ready to
start laughing off their genitals all
these people should be in prison all of
these people should be ostracized from
society there's no question about that
and i don't i don't want to hear any
states rights argument for it either
okay there's the kind of squish position
which is well listen
if california wants to lop off the
genitals of kids that's their business
that's their right that's no they don't
have a right to do that they don't scout
weiner doesn't have a right to do this
these quack doctors don't have a right
to do this the parents don't have a
right to do this either
and we're not only justified we actually
have an obligation to say that no so you
don't get to
you don't get to
put little kids through all sorts of
mutilations to make the little boy look
more like a little girl no one has the
right to do that there's no right from
democracy there's no right from the
sexual revolution or anything else when
they're not chopping up the little kids
they are they are killing the little
kids and a lot of other people too this
uh not just in california but up in
america's top hat canada
in canada now they are very heavily
pushing assisted suicide
they they use
a another euphemism it's not just
euthanasia
which was the one the euphemism for many
years for assisted suicide means a good
death even though it's not a good death
at all because suicide is the basically
the worst kind of death you can imagine
but now they call it made
maid medical assistance in dying
and canada in over the last six or so
years has been really aggressive in
pushing assisted suicide
to the point that we're not just talking
about a few marginal cases because i
know even there are a number of
conservatives sometimes who will say
well look if an old person has all sorts
of terrible diseases and is going
through an intense amount of pain
maybe in that rare case it should be
okay for that person to be able to kill
himself
i don't think that's true but i can see
why some people might start to believe
that
but the thing about assisted suicide is
it it cannot remain just a kind of
fringe one in a million kind of case
the moment that you legalize assisted
suicide
assisted suicide is going to explode and
it's going to become a huge percentage
of the of deaths every single year this
is what you're seeing in canada
only recently did canada really start to
legalize assisted suicide and start to
peddle this stuff now as of last year
over three percent of deaths in canada
are are through suicide or i'm sorry
through assisted suicide there are other
suicides as well
over three percent
that's a huge number and it's only going
to grow and now the canadians are going
to push it on little kids i'm not joking
there's a piece here
is in the ottawa citizen
on expanding medical assistance in dying
to mature minors
so what they're saying is no we're not
just going to kill any little kids
we're going to kill miners who are can
make their own decisions now the thing
about minors is they can't make their
own decisions that's why we have age of
consent laws that's why it is illegal
for you right now listening to this show
to sleep with a 16 year old you can't if
you're over whatever 19 or 20 or what i
don't know whatever the laws are in your
state if you're over
if you're if you're not a kid anymore
it is illegal for you to sleep with
someone who is a minor why is that
because we have age of consent laws
because we say that young people just
are not fully in command of their
faculties to make these kinds of
important decisions now the libs are
trying to turn that on their head
they're saying yes it's true a 16 year
old can't make a decision about whether
or not to have a one-night stand but a
six-year-old can make the decision about
whether to permanently destroy his or
her genitals and sterilize themselves
and give themselves all kinds of
problems and osteoporosis and all kinds
of persistent conditions for the rest of
their lives
because they do have autonomy they do
have agency
obviously they don't now canada is going
to take it even further they're going to
say hold my beer
hold hold my my labats hold my golden
molson sorry i'm just doing my jordan
peterson impression not only not only
are we going to let the children have a
one-night stand
is it becoming irish i don't know not
only are we going to let the kids
chop off their genitals
but we're going to let the kids kill
themselves as well sorry that's what
they're saying now that's insane
to clarify jordan peterson is not saying
that but all the lunatics up in canada
are saying that
they are saying that
and this is the logical conclusion of
course
it was always the logical conclusion of
all of this
which kids do you think are going to are
going to be killed through assisted
suicide do you think it's going to be
just the happy normal wellag no it's
going to be the disabled kids what this
is going to amount to
is
just another aspect of the system of
eugenics that the libs have been pushing
through
abortion primarily but now if they don't
get them at the very beginning of their
lives they're going to get them shortly
thereafter and they're going to say oh
you're a you're disabled you're sad
you're depressed
okay 12 year old well you can make the
mature and informed decision to kill
yourself and we're going to support you
in that
ghastly ghastly stuff
there was a news story that came out
yesterday that the largest child
sacrifice in human history has just been
excavated in peru
it was uh not the incas but it was the
civilization before the i for what
they're called the
chimayas or something it was the
civilization that the incas conquered
and they they found 450 child sacrifices
around the age of 10 or 12 in this
altar pit
i thought wow that's pretty bad but
those guys don't have anything on modern
westerners not even close
we sacrifice 850 000 babies a year
through abortion it's not even even the
aztecs on their worst day didn't didn't
get that far
and now look at what we're doing in
canada even if you want to say
implausibly i think that babies aren't
really babies that a baby if a baby's in
the womb the baby's not really a human
being or not really alive that's a silly
argument but okay now we're talking
about kids who are like eight we're
talking about kids who are 12
and canada is saying they're in a really
really serious sophisticated way that
justin trudeau you know smiley really
nice happy way yes we're gonna let the
disabled kids die we're gonna kill them
we're gonna have doctors kill the
disabled kids if they get a little sad
sometimes and that'll be better for
everybody don't you think no of course
not
of course not we all know that this is
evil
okay the left
is for it because the left supports evil
things that's just what the left is that
even the very term left in politics
comes out of the french revolution and
it was the people who sat on the left of
the national assembly who were attacking
the church it's just an attack on god
when it really gets down to it that's
what leftism is
so the we all know it's evil the left is
for it because the left supports evil
things and the right is just kind of
impotent because the the right can't
really articulate the definition between
good and evil some conservatives can but
the ones who have fallen into the
squishiness of the you do you and well
who's to say what's good or bad man or
don't force me to do anything or i'm not
going to impose my views on anybody man
whatever you know they adopt all of
these kind of silly
libertarian-ish platitudes
they can't articulate what to do about
this
the only language that the right has
been able to use in recent decades is
the language of autonomy the language of
choice
so they're going to say well
if they oppose this at all they're going
to say well it's wrong because
the kids can't choose the kids can't
freely consent
it's fine for adults to kill themselves
but it's wrong for kids because the kids
can't freely consent that's not
primarily what's wrong with it the thing
that's primarily wrong with it is that
it is always wrong to kill yourself it's
a grave grave sin because you do not own
your body you didn't bring yourself into
this world you have no right to bring
yourself out of this world your life is
a gift to you from god you are a steward
of yourself and your body and you have
responsibilities you don't just get to
do whatever the hell you want to do all
the time
you have
duties and responsibilities to the moral
order which is real
and which we in our country are are
denying every bit as much you want to
talk we talk about evil empires you know
the soviet union and what genuinely was
an evil empire and we talk about evil
empires like the aztecs and all those
people practicing human sacrifice down
there in latin america well i think the
moderns ought to take a little look in
the mirror okay
before you accuse me take a look at
yourself because the stuff that we're
delving into right now
really really wicked stuff would make
the aztecs
blush
speaking of bad things that everyone
seems to agree upon there is a new
trailer
that's out on netflix and this this one
shook me
i got really shook
the the trailer is for a show called
athena
and the show depicts a civil war in
which the arabs and the africans in
france over overthrow the french and
this results in a kind of a civil war
now the the trailer is in french so i
will harness all of my you know pepe le
pew linguistic uh
skills to translate it for you here's
the trailer
[Music]
do you see this guy who looks
i don't know arab or algerian or
something like that he's walking through
the streets
there's violence all around him
he is
he's walking he's on a mission and then
there's
words appearing on screen but it's not
fully there yet
[Music]
liberty
i greatly apologize for my poor french
pronunciation there
but it's by sophocles and so the the
line means
when
when destiny strikes when destiny
strikes
no one can escape the misfortune no
mortal person can escape
the misfortune and so what is this
predicting
this is saying this is destiny this is
fate you're going to have a race war in
france and it's going to cause the
collapse of the government and the
society and you're going to have a civil
war a war a war between the french
on one side and the africans and the
arabs on the other side and what's so
interesting about this to me
is that it's one that's being put out by
netflix so this is a lib vision of
society
and
the libs have talked about these kinds
of racial politics and oppression
narratives and overcoming and resistance
and toppling the powers that be for a
very long time
and you've also heard this kind of dread
on the right so that's from the left on
the right you've heard a kind of dread
which is gosh if we keep this stuff up
guys we're gonna have racial conflict
and you're gonna have this
and if we if we just flood the country
with migrants but we don't assimilate
any of them then you're gonna have a lot
of ethnic and racial conflict and that
could really lead to a lot of social
instability and what's so amazing to me
about the trailer is
everyone agrees on it
everyone seems to agree
that this
kind of conflict is not only possible
but maybe likely the line from sophocles
here is that it's destiny it's
inevitable that this is going to happen
the only difference here is that the
conservatives are saying this would be a
bad thing we dread this we don't want to
see this kind of conflict
and the libs seem to think it would be a
very good thing something heroic
something worth celebrating
this gets back to something i've cited a
number of times on this show recently
it's what mike anton calls the
celebration parallax
when the libs say something and then the
conservatives repeat verbatim what the
libs just said
the conservatives will be called crazy
conspiracy theorists
the libs are allowed to say it and
celebrate it but the moment the
conservatives repeat it
in a way to perhaps criticize it or warn
about it they're called crazy they're
not they're just simply not allowed to
say the very same thing that the libs
are
if a conservative made this show and
there have been some kind of far right
you know
dystopian visions of these kinds of
conflicts
it's always written off as it's this is
fascist the neo-nazi
far right wing horrible
crazy dystopian but then the libs come
out with the very same images and they
say wow beautiful yes slay queen this is
great
this is very scary it's very scary when
pretty much everyone in your society is
predicting
social collapse and racial conflict as
inevitable
even if one side likes it and one side
doesn't like it
that's very very scary when when
something seems so
imminent that everyone sees it coming
speaking of race wars
judicial watch sue has just sued a
school district over the minneapolis
public school teacher union contract
that explicitly discriminates against
white people i covered this probably a
month ago on the show this contract
where in minneapolis they the teachers
union signed on to say that if there are
ever going to be cuts to the teachers
the white people get cut first it just
establishes a racial hierarchy and says
we're going to discriminate against
whites even more than the schools
already are doing
so judicial watch which is a
conservative group announced that
they're suing on behalf of the
minneapolis taxpayer over this union
agreement
and
what does this all mean for us
normal people
of all races of all backgrounds and all
geographies
understand that it is wrong
to take a class of people on the basis
of their race or ethnicity and say we're
going to make you permanent second-class
citizens and we're going to take away
your jobs and we're going to
discriminate against you everyone knows
that you don't need to be a white person
to to be
shocked and offended by this story every
normal decent person of every single
race
understands that
the libs are just making a gamble here
they're saying if we run
on anti-white anti-male anti-christian
anti-tradition politics
anti-american in many cases
if we run on that
we're going to be able to cobble
together a coalition of enough angry
radicals to win elections might not even
be a majority but it could be a
plurality and we're going to win these
these elections and what are the
conservatives doing
nothing they're not addressing this they
have to address this
judicial watch has the right instinct
here the republican party
needs to articulate why this is wrong
they need to say there is anti-white
discrimination
in the minneapolis public school system
and it's wrong
and it's wrong in theory and it's wrong
in practice in in this particular case
republicans and conservatives don't want
to do that because we feel that it's
we've bought the liberal line we feel
that it's racist somehow to say that you
shouldn't discriminate against white
people i don't know how that's possible
but the libs just convinced us of that
because the libs say you can't you can't
be racist against white people so even
when the conservatives and the
republicans want to talk about the the
how awful race discrimination in
affirmative action is in schools and
hiring they never talk about the white
people
because they just feel it's kind of icky
let's not talk about they'll they'll
only talk about asians
so it happens to be the case and this is
a kind of unfortunate circumstance for
the asian people but a happy
circumstance for those who want to fight
against race discrimination called
affirmative action which is that
you could say well it's wrong to the
asian students that they're
discriminated against in harvard
admissions
yeah it is but it's it's wrong for the
white students too
well it's wrong when forget about the
white people for a sec it doesn't matter
when you discriminate against them but
the poor asian students yeah it's wrong
for the asian students it's wrong to be
cruel and discriminatory toward the
asian students and it's wrong to be
cruel and discriminatory toward black
students or hispanic students or
whatever
and
it is wrong it is just as wrong
to be cruel and discriminatory toward
white people
are we allowed to say that i don't know
i know i can i can hear people going a
little quiet when you because you're not
i don't know why you're not allowed to
say that it seems so obvious
and everyone gets it every normal person
sensible person gets it the only people
who don't seem to get it are the
republican political consultants who
want to run away from this stuff okay
the reason that republicans are doing
well right now in spite of republican
political consultants
is that ordinary people across a whole
wide range of demographics realize that
the democrats have lost the plot here
and they just want to hear people talk
to them like a normal person that's why
donald trump did so well too he talked
to people like a normal person and he
addressed political issues like a normal
person and he wasn't totally politically
correct and he didn't parse all of his
language all the time and he called a
spay to spade that's what we got to do
speaking of white people
i've got the most white people story in
the world right now
and it's a very important day and even i
a swarthy american really i identify
with my white brothers and sisters here
mostly white sisters mostly teenage
white girls it's pumpkin spice latte day
yes i know that many conservatives don't
like the pumpkin spice latte they don't
like starbucks very much
i don't care i love it i love it it is a
delicious drink it is nostalgic it is is
wonderful it's a little too sweet you
got to bring the sugar down a little bit
it i look forward to it every single
year it's a sign of the times the the
beginning of my new of my favorite
season autumn it's wonderful okay
but i've got some bad news
for the pumpkin spice latte aficionados
out there all of the 17 year old white
girls who listen to this show
the price of the psl has increased
dramatically
according to a report from cnn
the psl will will go up from five
dollars and 45 cents that is so
outrageous five oh my that's what i'm
paying for this thing that is such a
that is a crime never mind
5.40 45 cents to 5.95
that's a 4 increase and i can't even
blame starbucks inflation is up year
over year at eight and a half percent
so it's not start starbucks only raised
to 4
not even 8 and a half percent
i will never
forgive joe biden for this
i will it was one thing you know when he
caused the war in ukraine and flooded
the country with illegal aliens and
destroyed the economy and
that was all bad and called us all
fascists
i will never forgive him
for raising the price of the pumpkin
spice latte but this is a message from
our elites okay yes it's going to hurt
the democrats in the midterms because
the economy is not doing well
but this was a plan you had barack obama
in 2008 saying we need fuel prices to go
up that's how we're going to get on the
green agenda you have people who show up
to davos who are part of the kind of
global
cosmopolitan set who say well we
actually need certain prices to go up
that's what's going to force people into
a greener more interconnected less
national more globalist kind of world
and they're getting exactly what they
want the time is upon us for another
backstage it's happening tonight 6 p.m
central 7 p.m eastern
it's about time because there's more
news than ever to discuss if you've
never seen backstage before it is where
we all get together
it's me ben matt drew the god king
jeremy boring for a round table
discussion on the most burning topics of
the day jokes will be cracked cigars
will be smoked libations will be imbibed
you definitely do not want to miss this
one tune in to join us for backstage
tonight 6 p.m central 7 pm eastern
dailywireplus.com
all of these stories the collapse of our
political order especially the collapse
of our economy the four percent hike on
the price of the pumpkin spice latte all
of that ties back in
to france
we're just talking about france and the
imagined civil war that's about to break
out
emmanuel macron the leader of france
just came out and i think he spoke for
the entire western elite when he said
you know what this is all about guys
it's you want too much you desire too
much you've got it too good and you've
got to say goodbye
to abundance
what we are living through is a time of
great upheaval
firstly because we are witnessing and
not just since this summer but over the
past few years
the end of what we might have seen as
abundance
and for those who enjoyed it it is also
the end of a carefree time
our freedom the liberty to which we have
grown accustomed to in our lives has a
price and sometimes when we have to
defend it we have to make certain
sacrifices as we fight to defend it
it's the end of abundance that's what it
is that's
that's what the message is from the
elite
and it reminds us
it really it's important to take those
lessons from
from history especially the fall of the
soviet union
and for many other empires too
while the economy is humming along
you can paper over a lot of problems
when the economy stops those problems
leap to the fore this is why irving
crystal who's kind of the og neocon the
og neocons were actually pretty smart
and interesting the the the term became
really poisoned because the second
generation neocons had a bunch of stupid
terrible policies and they all became
never trumpers and they're just like
gadflies in american politics but the
oge neocons people like irving crystal
were really smart people and irving
crystal
made the point that conservatism
conservatism today he was saying this in
the 60s and 70s
is
religion
nationalism and economic growth
which is super based to use an
anachronistic word there that's not
that's not the kind of language we
expect here from the neocons because the
the neo-neocons have really kind of
changed and spoiled the whole thing but
religion totally agree nationalism
absolutely
and economic growth that one's important
too
you you do need some prosperity
in order to keep the society humming
along
when you start taking away people's gas
and oil
when you start taking away people's food
when you start raising the price of the
pumpkin spice latte
people start to become a little bit
impatient
and you get a little bit a little bit
more
chaos
speaking of abundance
meghan markle is back in the news i'm
sorry to say
meghan markle
the former duchess of sussex married
prince harry this american bio weapon
that was we probably built in a lab here
i wonder if dr fauci built meghan markle
in a lab on at the behest of the us
government to destroy the british royal
family because that's certainly what
she's been doing she uh we sent her over
there then they sent her back he said no
we don't want her
you can take harry too we don't want him
either so meghan markle
very very unlikable public figure
meghan markle comes out and has just
compared her
marrying into the royal family her
becoming an actual princess
to nelson mandela
being freed from prison
meghan markle has a new podcast because
every millennial has to have a podcast
that's a federal law now i think meghan
markle on her podcast claims that when
she attended the lion king in london
a cast member pulled her aside and just
said i need you to know
when you married into this family we
rejoiced in the streets the same we did
when mandela was freed from prison
the grandson of nelson mandela the south
african leader uh did not like this
comment from meghan markle
understandably so what does this tell
you it tells you that the victim
narrative especially in america
but throughout the western world but
especially in america
is so
so powerful i bet she believes it
i bet meghan markle one of the most
privileged people on earth
actual royalty
believes that she is a victim
like a political dissident
being imprisoned for years
that's it and the narrative is very very
strong
and so we cannot
we can either
complain about it or we can try to make
it work in our favor
okay donald trump actually did this
donald trump did not exactly take the
high road in 2016. he was attacked for
that i said donald you're just playing
the victim you're just crying and
complaining
you need to stop complaining donald and
what did trump say he said you know what
i'm going to do
i'm going to complain complain complain
complain complain complain complain i'm
going to wine wine wine wine wine until
i win
and what what trump i i don't know if
this was conscious or just subconscious
because the guy's got a good gut he was
saying i'm going to play american
politics where it actually is
you're all going to play american
politics where the bow tie said in the
think tanks over the fancy lunches
wishes that it were but me that's not
what i'm going to do i'm going to play
american politics right where it lives
i'm not going to present my case to the
american people in a series of white
papers when people ask donald trump hey
what are you going to do as president he
goes you know what i want i want great
neighborhoods
i want there to be great neighborhoods
okay that's going to be my job as
president and all the bow tie people and
all the think tank people they said oh
my gosh no that's not what the for all
of the federal government actually that
what we need to do is take that power
out of washington dc then send that back
to the states and the local government
deal with the county governments and
then and you know what the american
people here the the sort of average
voter here is uh
what shut up nerd
shut up nerd i hate my neighborhood
there's guns everywhere there's drugs on
the streets there's some bum defecating
on my sidewalk yeah i'm gonna vote for
the guy that gives me a good
neighborhood thank you very much
no but actually you don't understand
because of the principle of federalism
you have no
no
and you know trump might understand that
as well you know i mean i'm
pro-federalism i'm pro-restoring a
coherent political order
but we've got we got drugs everywhere
we've got the average life expectancy in
the united states declining we got
people chopping off the genitals of
little kids we've got crime going
through the roof so
forgive me if when we're campaigning and
talking to real human beings with real
problems and real concerns
we take it out of the pie in the sky for
a second and say oh yeah you see that
problem that problem in your life if you
elect me i'm going to do my very best to
fix it that's what we got to do
speaking of victims in their
neighborhoods this video just went viral
it's actually captured on a ring
doorbell cam
of a guy a 22 year old guy
who
tries to bust into his ex-girlfriend's
house and the ex-girlfriend's living
with her family obviously they're pretty
young people and she says go away you
know no i'm not letting you in and he he
won't take no for answering he just
starts trying trying to bust down the
door here's what happens
so door's locked
he starts just trying to shoulder it in
trying to bust in through it
it's not happening
you hear the guy inside he goes i got a
gun get out of here doesn't matter he
keeps trying to bust in the door
and then the guy with the gun really had
a gun shoots the guy
the guy goes down the guy is dead
your first reaction to this video
will tell me everything i need to know
about your political views
this video it's a sad video i mean you
don't you don't really see the guy die
on camera
mercifully but you see him he gets shot
he kind of stammers off the camera
if your first reaction to this video is
oh that that kid that poor kid oh no can
you hear this country we have too many
guns like that's so unnecessary they
didn't have to if that's your first
reaction then you're a lib then you're a
leftist then your view of justice is
just kind of messed up
if your first take watching that video
is oh sad that the house the the owner
of the house had to do that but he did
what he had to do and he protected his
daughter then your view of justice and
politics is
going to be conservative and right-wing
and correct
and that's it and it
it tells me a lot about american
politics too because in on the way the
camera is set up right just by virtue of
it being a doorbell
all you see
is the guy who gets shot
so so you say well he must be the victim
he's not the victim he's the perpetrator
what the hell was he going to do to that
poor girl the girl in the house says dad
i think he's going to kill me what's he
getting
could you imagine you're you're in a
home you're saying i have a gun go away
stop trying to break into my home and
then the guy keeps coming in
i don't think that guy's there to talk i
don't think that guy's there to have tea
i think that guy's there to do bad bad
things
but the perspective here is everything
because a lot of people are looking at
that and they're going to say all that
poor he's the victim they shouldn't the
the dad should have shot him in the leg
or whatever whatever nonsense that
people who've never held a firearm in
their lives say
the dad should have fired a warning shot
you know joe biden he should have fired
a shotgun into the air yeah that's a
good idea joe
but that's the perspective you don't you
don't see the camera's not on
the father who's defending his home and
his daughter the camera's not on the
daughter who the hell knows what that
guy has already done had already done or
would have done to that daughter
that's it and that that perspective is
so key
and a really important rule for politics
that i would strongly recommend is that
we get a lot better about turning the
camera
okay when we the libs always talk about
how you know the poor victims
of the war on drugs you know the drug
dealers those poor victims
so it's so wrong that we lock up all the
drug dealers working for the mexican
cartels that's so terrible peddling
poison to little kids uh what victims
they're not the victims they're the
perpetrators
the victims are the people who die
because some some
pill peddler you know gave them gave
them some drugs outside of their school
the victims are the family members of
the poor kids who die
the victims are the american people
where the average life expectancy goes
down you got to turn the camera you got
to turn the perspective a little bit
the the issue with victim culture is not
even that
there are no such thing as victims it's
that the people who are pretending to be
victims are usually the perpetrators in
victim culture and maybe if we paid a
little more attention to the actual
victims we'd be a lot better off it's
kind of like cancel culture problem with
cancel culture is not that we have
standards and we say you can and can't
say certain things it's that in in our
current cancel culture
if if you say the truth you'll get
cancelled and if you say false things
false things you'll get promoted that's
actually what my uh
kind of video essay on youtube is about
where we have all the receipts and we
talk about the social media
blacklist campaign that went on for two
and a half years that's the issue the
issue is not that we cancel people it's
that we cancel good things and promote
bad things when really it should be
the opposite now you know the rest of
the show is continuing now you do not
want to miss it if you are not a member
click the link in the description and
join us and speaking of that member
block tomorrow on my show during the
exclusive member portion we are going to
be talking to kirk cameron he'll be
stopping by the studio for an exclusive
interview if you are not a daily wire
plus member be sure to sign up today so
that you can have access to the full
show exclusive interviews and the uh
interview tomorrow with kirk cameron and
if you didn't catch it yesterday we
interviewed the podium guy from january
6th so you can go check that out a
delightful interview okay let's get to
the member block we'll see you over
there
[Music]
[Music]
you